I want to talk about HP to this at
transgender bathroom law in North
Carolina as you probably know the law
passed in March it requires transgender
people to use the bathroom that
corresponds with their birth certificate
gender and this is in schools and state
government buildings somewhat less
commonly known is that the law also
excludes gender identity and sexual
orientation from anti-discrimination
protections in the state that's the
background of the law we now see
Republican leaders reeling because the
n-c-double-a has pulled seven
Championships out of North Carolina over
this ridiculous law we've already seen
seen some pressure imposed on North
Carolina by collegiate sports and
college sports is huge in North Carolina
that's why it makes a really really
potentially big impact but now the NCAA
has said we're pulling out seven
championships here the NBA has canceled
some stuff there rock stars have
canceled concerts etc and the idea is to
continue to put financial pressure on
the NC double-a it's already projected
I'm sorry on the state of North Carolina
by the NC double-a we are estimating
that 20 million dollars will be lost in
revenue from the cancellation of next
year's basketball baseball soccer tennis
lacrosse and golf events and I started
thinking Rachel if this works at getting
North Carolina to repeal HB 2 is it
really a victory because clearly they
wouldn't at this point repeal the law
because that horrific and deplorable Pat
McCrory says you know what it's not a
good law it's an unfair law we should
cancel it we should undo it it would
only be because they are losing money
and we are sort of against the idea of
entities just doing what they need to do
in order to not lose money we talked
about this with corporate media etcetera
so I truly don't know if this does work
to get hb2 repealed should I be glad or
should I still realize that wait a
second North Carolina is still just as
deplorable they still have the exact
same position on this issue they might
just change the law because they want to
recuperate that money
I think it's kind of a double-edged
sword because I think that if it does
end up working and the NCAA holds the
kind of weight that it does to attract
attention to this issue then that could
be a victory because in fact they are
getting it to be changed but at the same
time knowing the circumstance stances
under which it is changed yeah does make
me think okay well if they're still
going to be this horrible kind of
deplorable morals and values that I
don't agree with but if at the end of
the day it is changing then I think it
has to be a victory no matter what the
reason for the law change it would still
impact what a transgender individual is
able to do in the state so in that way
we should be glad if it's repealed no
matter what the circumstances however we
would know that it was only financial
pressure not any feeling of
responsibility to the reality that this
law is a disaster for transgender
individuals that would have gotten a lot
change but I think I at the in the end
at the end of the day I think your point
is right which is if you're transgender
in North Carolina even if its financial
pressure that gets the law changed it's
still changing what your day to day is
in terms of how you're able to to exist
in public right also and I think that if
something like the NCAA is kind of
bringing this type of attention that has
to be in a positive way as what and what
I was kind of saying before because if
they didn't kind of take this opinion or
this type of statement on how they felt
about this issue then that they would be
saying nothing at all I feel like making
a comment is better I completely support
the NC double-a doing this there's no
doubt about it and really I'm just more
interested in the potential implications
my view of North Carolina's government
their Republican legislature and Pat
McCrory even if this is repealed my
opinion would not change about them